this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
soon Citroen tending bar what in walks
someone that's pretty easy to recognize
Sub Zero he didn't seem to happen at
Mia's face or at least I could tell by
his eyes that's all I could see so I'll
make him a margarita and I see one of
course and that's a boy so what seems to
be the problem
I says oh just not doing that got it my
children I said don't you enjoy being a
world-class fighter don't you enjoy the
fact that you can shoot freezing beams
out of your hands and freeze people and
doctor blocks off I says oh that's all
fine I mean I've been trained to be a
killer
a warrior take down as many horrible
people as I can and spare no blood and
violence doing all of it but at the same
time you have to pay the bills and being
a mortal combat fighter isn't my
full-time job
that's not a wealthy what is your
I said being an ice-cream man I'll say
Oh sub-zero no he said yeah yeah it's
the sad truth on an ice-cream man some
cones is what it says on the side of the
truck master how did you get a job doing
that they says well obviously I'll keep
the treats cold I mean that's a
no-brainer
but at the same time I guess I got the
job in the you know late eighties early
nineties so was that they said because
the people who looked at me and hired me
for the job thought I was a mascot they
thought I was representing a team called
the New England Turtles and I was the
shredder doesn't even make sense he was
the villain so I'm the villain mascot of
a team were supposed to be rooting for
when I beat solve an anti mascot so they
thought the whole blue ninja thing
looked pretty child friendly and I'll
said they thought you looked child
friendly I said remember I'm not
scorpion there's not a skull under my
face while I take my mask off though
lord knows they'll either scare away a
lot of kids or bring more kids to em I'm
not sure on top of that it won't be able
to keep the treats cold and he just
licks the thing and what we melt but
I'll go Chris I said being an ice cream
man can't be all that bad I mean it's
better than going out there risking your
life every day as a fighter he says you
would think wouldn't you I would go
through eight rounds eight rounds with
Shane song if it meant never having to
hear give me a spongebob snow pop again
sometimes it's not bad he says what for
example Astaire playing the typical
ice-cream man theme that they play over
the speakers he plays the Mortal Kombat
music after about 10 seconds there's a
rave going on in the middle of the
street glow sticks the whole shebang it
was going goodies until the kids start
doing jello shots children are learning
norm or these states are getting their
crafty and I said I know what you mean I
mean kids they can be tough can't they a
says earlier especially this one
his name is Georgia he said and
just a little puke always comes up and
always yells at me and oh it's makes fun
of my costume at least in Mortal Kombat
I can beat the shit out of somebody I
don't like but here you have to smile
and be happy I said they can see your
smile he says they can see a smile it's
like telemarketing they can hear it over
the phone in fact that's what happened
with this Georgia kid the other day he
told me he didn't see me smiling no I
said I didn't want to smile and they
said why are you sad that your mommy
hates you because she raised an ice
cream truck driver and not something
cool like a fighter miserable blue piece
of shit I said he said that largely
seppuku but that means the same thing
and I personally knew for a fact that
sub-zero was very sensitive about his
mom she was a snowman you seen and
apparently made love to one of the
ninjas from ninja gaiden he apparently
lost her very early because she
apparently vanished in summer he doesn't
know it the details and I said Oh some
what did you do to this kid that was
insulting your mother he says he froze
him in a decapitated him man what biting
the head off an animal cracker he said
oh well that's murder is an Isis know if
you don't get caught Georgiy always want
to eat up all the kids attention well
guess what now all the kids are eating
up him I said good God and they says not
what Georgie thought the kids had no
idea they're actually digesting the
bully they used to pick on him every day
and I figured it was my way to give back
to society as a subzero that's the most
disturbing thing I ever heard
and you're from Mortal Kombat they said
most disturbing that when DC Comics did
a crossover with us and I said yeah it's
much more disturbing what's to stop me
from calling the police right now I
asked him
I said well I didn't tell you about my
new job you see I deliver ice now your
ice
just then they looked down at the icy
margarita I made in minutest an eyeball
he said if you want to keep the people
in charge of health code violations I
above here I'll do my best to keep other
people's eyes out of here too I had to
say it but I shook his hand and agreed
I'll guess you could take the sick
bastard out of the tournament but you
can't take the tournament out of the
sick bastard is the OL strange things as
a bartender you see a lot of strange
things at the pixel palace so I'll see
almost drinks things as a bartender at
the pixel palace that ain't no line
sweat Owen incidentally if you ever tell
anyone about that health code violation
I'll be dead in the water so when do we
start recording